what's the dream today money money do
that I want to point off from the house
if you are absolutely flat broke yeah
how can you benefit from the house hey
what's up on Samuel Leeds and today's a
really excited day I'm so excited
because there's this lady called cloak
cloak came to the crash course she's
been putting loads of post up on
Facebook she's booking so many Ewing's
the thing is she's got absolutely no
money she says she can't even get to
doing petrol money and my plan is today
she's got loads of viewings in Burnley
so I came down with my mum I was there
and what we're gonna do see if they're
any good if they are we are gonna
package one of their deals and sell it
today and my plan is that clothes going
to make 2,000 pound today two damaged
there will be good because she's been to
the crash course two thousand pound
today that's the plan oh that I think
that I think that would be just
incredible so she has no idea that I'm
here or Alistair's yeah she watches his
podcast she's been to my crash course so
she's on the carpark now and my video
team I've gotta get a check she's okay
and then I'm gonna go out and surprise
her and help her make some money I don't
know what that means but I'm excited but
so do you think and no captain
how many bookings we have to do I a
booking yes yeah there you are oh my
goodness it's cold
oh my god how are you glad you made it
oh my god excited so we've got some
viewings in the house today
surprise
you know expect the skeptical Scotsman
to be here I put a Facebook post out and
I said whoever books the most Furies I'm
gonna send one of my team to go with the
person in cloak bucked like 50 or 51
viewings just saying how many of you
she's doing I was just like damn I need
to send someone but uh but then I
thought well I was free so I thought
I'll come down myself I'll get my bags
so good to see you I'm glad you're here
we're gonna have a great day
you're gonna learn so much today
honestly do you know what though every
time with you a house it's gonna be like
a mini crash course we totally got you
today all right okay you know they say
it all starts in the crash policy it
doesn't start for crash course you have
to walk the ABC then you figure out the
expose day and what you've been doing in
booking viewings is you've just been
actually throwing yourself in it out
there looking at deals finding
opportunities and because you did that
here the XYZ a bit now so what come out
and we'll see if we can just help put a
strategy together we're here our first
viewing of the day how did you kind of
choose this I know where you've put into
the crash course spectrum a little bit
but how did you choose this particular
Street and speaking to a lot of estate
agents and finding out what areas is
gonna work what the rental is like
property size so the problem with this
house for HMO purposes it's just that
the rooms are a bit too small
so obviously this room perfect size but
these little rooms aren't really big
enough and I think as well something
really interesting is the rules are 70
square feet but it's kind of also common
sense this rooms even smaller
I generally say if you can fit a bed a
chest of drawers and a wardrobe and
still have enough space to walk around
it's big enough this room can fit a bed
just about I wouldn't call this a chest
of drawers it's tiny and if you had a
wardrobe it would suddenly just look
it's impossible I think we're done here
on to the next one with this house is a
little bit overpriced
it's on 410 we know this house is
setting in the street flat 80 90 grand
pungent ends a little overpriced as
single that you're only gonna get like
500 top-end it's not gonna stack as a
single that as HMO the rooms are a bit
too small so whilst the street brilliant
and close them really well find in the
agent and find them straight
it just isn't been a stack there's no
angle of where we can do this this is
hard work
but it's great fun I love it this is
what I have to do every day
damn it oh my goodness looks like he's
open most of my life I've been a dog
trainer yeah I love I love dogs I love
animals so I've been yeah doing dog
training and dog shows and that's how I
got into the rosette business through
making them from my own shows and things
all that and you know doing a lot of
shows a charity and things I've always
been interested in property but it's
more like you drive past and think that
would make something and then you just
drive past it that's the sort of level
and then I started viewing but then I
got told by people what's the point in
viewing if you're not going to buy it
and it's only when after the crash
course that you get told there are more
than more than just you have to say for
deposit and buy it yourself how finance
is right now okay why why finance is OB
don't want me asking personal questions
why they're so tight I can answer this
but I can't answer it on film my plan
and haven't told by this but I really
badly hope there's a property that's
good enough for me to package and sell I
don't want these day to end without Chlo
having more money in her bank and she
had when she woke up this morning the
best thing she just make a sale get
cheaper and can you give the club
confidence your first day always always
your holiday steals a shake you just
packing something and sell it and make a
couple grand it's gonna give us such
confidence and then the next step will
be to joint venture with somebody and
maybe they put the funds in and this you
can manage the property you know we can
we can work some stuff out but and they
just gotta take you step by turned and
really excited
because it's a refurb project the street
that's basically just three figures look
at first price we know bike about a
hundred grand so it's on four what's the
cost of the refurb i reckon at least
forty I don't know what you think but
there's a lot to do last thing is the N
value so I would probably suggest that
we speak to the council it almost feels
a little bit haunted oh okay you know
you know what this could be half his
bedroom it's gonna be Pam's bedroom
[Laughter]
[Music]
whole street is like boarded up bad sign
even if on paper it looks great you're
gonna get the wrong kind of tenants and
I don't even need to go inside
it's just absolute no god that's me I do
okay put on your crash course and we're
down as well yeah right good stuff so
what you view it well many people in
that but just had the cool fun wait what
is that we were but then one important
person you were like maybe we'll skip
this one look good on paper
look what I'm right move but the street
is a dump you have to go to the houses -
yes yeah you got you cannot just look on
Rightmove send somebody some you need to
actually go and look at the street yeah
the kitchens good however multi let you
need half a meter a tipper yes no this
is just just about the right amount low
maintenance garden perfect let's hope
that the rooms are big enough now so it
says that the smallest bedroom is 7 7 by
11 you'd need to get fire escape windows
and there's a gem of all of thumb is if
I can get out of the window then anyone
can
ah yes this is a fire escape window
although I'd probably rather burn but
anyway that's the story and did I go
down well thick without very walls oh
that's good
reviewed a few houses so far and there's
always been something either the the
area's been good but the rooms have been
too small or the areas be bad so we're
kind of like halfway through the day now
and we haven't actually seen anything
that's we're gonna be able to like do
much with so just really hoping that
this next one is good I think it is it
looks good on paper but you just never
know until we get inside so yeah it's
really hoping because we've only got
obviously a few more hours so really
hoping that this one is good about the
house for years yeah what did you put
did you pay for it up here a PCP file at
that house
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'll catch the original Big John
Reybold John you're on camera we are in
Burnley right now we are in what's known
the straight does that ring any bells
[Music]
what I wish you went out for so 440
pounds a month the bottom room how much
when do you get for the whole house wow
that's good
so here think low I think that would be
a great for better hm ah yes he's a
little bit worked into it yeah he bought
it for 65 he's doing it up it doesn't
need a little bit of work to do still
but the thing that you can't be is the
location right next to the football
ground walking distance you know you can
just tell with the area it's just like
nice it's just ah you cannot tell them
pictures but oh I think that house is
really good I think it's great I think
that it would rent out easy-peasy
he's got three doubles one single
they're all big enough the kitchens got
half a meter of work top per tenant and
we know what he'll accept we know that
he'll accept somewhere between 70 and 75
but 75 grand for a four bit HMO right
snap bang in the centre next step now I
want to talk to Luke they hate to my
management guy and just ask him what he
thinks of the rentability of this house
but like from your point of view from a
team or management point of view you
think I would rent over you pound a week
- do it - really nice standard I mean
you had mcmanager
I could take of it for you yeah you've
got what we wanted to achieve law yeah
because he's just confirmed the rental
demand than that other property
I want to strategize and I want to put
an offer on that last house okay so
what's the plan um I don't know
okay we'll review lots of houses yes we
just need a really good house yes what
were you hoping to get out of by the end
of the day knowledge okay call what else
what anything I can get out of that what
like I say just you know knowledge
obviously you know is important awesome
what else do you want what's the dream
today
money money okay it's about house that
we viewed seventy five thousand pounds
smack bang in the center for letter
ballrooms hmmm management company in
place about fourteen hundred pound a
month rent cracking house but the
question is if you are absolutely flat
broke how can you benefit from that
house try and find an investor maybe for
an investor or package it on okay now
I've got investors yes so I'd be very
happy to try and do a deal and try and
sell it what do you make at the moment a
month doing whatever you do about a week
and make a month salary in a day how
would that be you'd be happy with that
yeah or maybe just a little bit more a
little bit more would be lovely the
grand that'll be lovely how about we
call the guy yep and we put an offer
forward yep we secure it then we draft
an email
yeah and I will let you use than the
email out okay but I'll let you send it
to all of my investors okay but the
first step is we need to put enough on
the house I've got the guy's number so
do you want to speak to it I can do or
you can do it and then I can learn from
you how about I do you a deal because I
want you to really step out you come
visit okay I need you phone him ran okay
and you put the offer on but then I'll
speak to the investor you can learn from
that
okay so 75 is the offer
no no what's the offer needs to be less
you tell me what your frizam well he
said that he's turned down
for the 70 yeah he's got he has got
viewings on it yeah he's just dropped
you from 18 to 75 we need to be really
specific with the number so I would say
why don't we go in the 72 500
disappointment okay well we can call the
agent
they're gonna ask you if you're buying
it cash on mortgage and you're just
gonna say mortgage have you got a
mortgage in principle yes just speaking
on behalf of the buyer but then they're
gonna then go away they're going to come
back and they get to the opportunity
accepted or it's not been accepted if
it's been accepted then what you're
gonna do is you're going to say awesome
I'll email you all of my proofing
deposit with another as if it is you
then when you email them you're just
gonna say hi the property is going to be
going in the name of we're gonna put the
buyer and then we're going to put all
the buyers details and all their proof
of stuff see see the buyer in and then
we walk away hi yeah my name is Chloe I
came to view a property today and with
yourself yeah I'd like to put in an
offer please for the property 72 500
please okay that's wonderful thank you
okay thank you bye next step we need to
draft an email but what I'm thinking is
on the email we'll say 75 that way if he
says yes to 7,500 then we can say to
investor actually guess what great news
it's actually 7,500 okay dear investor
potential HM are available in Burnley
four bedrooms five K works needed aprox
walking distance to Burnley Center and
I'll put in brackets 10 minutes what are
the other selling points the rent
yes achievable went what would you say
she will rent his based on what Luke
said well he was saying fourteen hundred
but let's put thirteen hundred because
you always want to be you know under
under-promise and over-deliver I'm gonna
put agreed sale seventy five thousand
again we think you'll be seventy two and
a half thousand I'm gonna port HMO
manager and they charge I think they
they say what they charge now we need to
find out what they charge contact
available and I'm going to port finder's
fee two thousand pounds plus that
they'll send it to us and then we'll
pass on monies to yourself compliant
sorcerer with Ombudsman to reserve text
kind regards Samuel weeds annoyingly the
agent can get back to us it got to five
o'clock we couldn't get hold of the
owner but we frantically tried to find
him down and we did everything we liked
the house this is close Chloe's awesome
we viewed a lot of houses today she
would like to make an offer so you can
do the negotiations thank you very much
yeah I'd like to put in an offer please
of 70 to 500 for me
did that cover new flat I'm binging on
feed you and I've got the hull how about
65 yet with more really looking in the
house you know how much we're gonna have
to spend on that there and look what I
have spent more running myself I don't
know booth I don't think we can go
higher than 75 but we're ready to go
we've got the phones come on that will
get over the edge don't you fee and a
half I can do everything I've got what
do that fantastic
how do you feel good or just completely
to do we just bought a property and
we've just you've done it now we need to
sell the deal we've got a lot of
investors one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 20 messages of investors that
of text means idea I'm interested in do
and again max had max has had a similar
amount takes him as well so let me call
Paul we said the higher price no even
negotiated loss us bargaining power yes
yes all right so you're gonna listen
okay hopefully he'll know who I am are
you sure you don't do the talking you've
done a lot today though really really
have hi Paul how you doing this it's
it's Samuel Leeds how you doing dude I'm
so glad to talk to you the reason I'm
calling yourself literally I'm actually
with Alice there I think I think you
messaged it about the Burnley property
so I've actually just seen it I'm
literally outside it we've just got a
second viewing I just wondered I mean
what's your thoughts are you are you are
you interested in that one as well okay
cool well basically you know how it
works
find us very refundable fee either of
you time to do your due diligence you're
in good hands are you in a position
where you get the thief percent over
tonight all right cool what I'll do I'll
send you over all the details terms and
conditions
invoice for two thousand plus back as
soon as it's as soon as that sent over
drop me a message and yeah we'll support
you all the wife you very welcome
all right look forward to working with
you once again hope to see you real soon
I hope to see you real soon have
yourself a wonderful evening I'll get
that pinned over way causing it I'll
drop him a voice now because I don't
wanna have to call him back because the
call was done anyway how easy is that
do you know what that's called that's
called having a good reputation yes
because the deal was so big how fast did
he buy that deal I love Paul I've never
spoke to you before I don't know who he
is I don't know he obviously knows me
it's not about you know 2,000 plus but
for the deal in Berlin and also terms
and conditions like now as soon as
possible
thanks very much this is just like a
dream this is an absolute dream this is
this is everything that I want you going
through some promises putting an offer
get it accepted you know find an
investor they want it all it's just it's
just amazing this is how it's done this
is how it's done
I have loved working with Clos because
she's positive she's hard-working she's
smart she's driven she's ambitious and
her future is so bright it burns my eyes
she the great thing about Paul is he's
an investor he gets it he's literally
just paying for our time yeah so he's
not going oh I don't know what I'm doing
he's saying I know I'm doing I'm a
serious investor yeah I've got a lot of
properties but I got time to go drive
around Burnley yeah I've been a really
high paid job I just want to invest in
property and I want someone to do all
the running around for me and if I have
to pay 2 grand to close to go and view 8
houses and run around and talk to all
these people and negotiate and be out in
the dark negotiating with a man like
yeah have you 2 grand
yeah have you 2 grand just give me the
house this is just giving me so much
confidence so it's yeah it's just like
you know I found a property that you all
agree with that you could package and
sell it's just like you know it's total
confirmation that you know I can do it
it's absolutely amazing I'll never doubt
myself again 2,400 pound Burnley HMO in
the bank money in the bank
congratulations thank you how do you
feel thank you so much so you're 2,000
pound up
I am Cheers I'm so proud of you well
done it's almost priceless the knot with
the knowledge is just priceless and to
complete something like this you know
say this is what I've done and this is
the outcome of it is just it's it's just
incredible and to do the first one with
you lot is just amazing it's a lot of
money to me it's a lot of money to me
super proud of Chloe she made two
thousand pounds today from scratch when
she woke up this morning she did not
know that she was going to see me today
really really happy and really really
proud a plug so massive Congrats well
good job mate thanks Sarah I hope you
enjoyed the challenge be inspired be
blessed go kick some ass
thank you to be honest is really not
enough and it was just amazing and I've
had the best time